So, the Season 5 finale of Game Of Thrones
has been and gone, but it's left a shed-load
of questions in its wake.
I've already talked about what the future
holds for Jon Snow and the Night's Watch.
In this video, I'm going to look at where
things are headed for Cersei after her Walk
Of Atonement, and also how this links up with
the future for Jaime and the Martells storyline
in Dorne in Season 6.
There's going to be speculation and possible
spoilers for the show and the books in this
video!
Just before we start, I've got another great
giveaway from our friends at Ten Stickers
who have some insanely cool Game Of Thrones
products as well as loads of other fab movie
and TV stickers.
Details of the giveaway are in the description
below.
All you need to do is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video about the Lannisters
or Dorne.
Remember the flashback we had at start of
season to the prophecy young Cersei received
from Maggy the Frog?
Well in the proophecy she was told she would
wed a king and she married Robert Baratheon
And she was also told someone younger & more
beautiful would come along to take everything
she held dear.
Well Margaery Tyrell took both her royal title
& her son.
And, as for her children, she was told that:
"gold will be their crowns.
Gold their shrouds."
Joffrey was crowned king & poisoned at the
Purple Wedding in Season 4.
Myrcella was also poisoned in the Season 5
finale after a kiss from Ellaria Sand, who
was avenging the death of her lover Oberyn
Martell.
Now, of course, Myrcella hasn't been crowned
queen, but "gold will be their crowns" could
have a figurative meaning and just refer to
her golden hair.
When the effects of the poison took hold,
Myrcella was sailing back to King's Landing
and enjoying a tender moment with Jaime Lannister,
the man she said she always knew was her father.
But, of course, this is Game Of Thrones, so
that father-daughter bonding lasted about
10 seconds before blood started trickling
from Myrcella's nose and she died.
In the end, then, Oberyn was wrong when he
told Cersei that "We don't hurt little girls
in Dorne."
And Cersei was right when she replied, "Everywhere
in the world they hurt little girls."
Oh, and I'm sure that Cersei won't forget
the fact that Tyrion was behind Myrcella's
Dornish betrothal, and will likely blame him
for Myrcella's murder, just as she did for
Joffrey's.
That, of course, leaves Tommen as the final
Lannister child on the list to die.
And if things continue the way they have,
with one death in season 4, another in season
5, then Tommen looks scheduled to meet his
poisonous end in season 6!
Obviously, the Tyrells could be out for revenge,
and we they've got form for poisoning people
like Joffrey.
So perhaps we could see them teaming up with
Littlefinger again.
But let's go back for a moment, as I want
to talk about what Myrcella's death means
for Season 6.
Throughout Season 5, Prince Doran has been
very keen on keeping the peace between the
Martells in Dorne and the Lannisters in King's
Landing.
And each time Ellaria Sand and the Sand Snakes
have tried to hatch a plan to get some revenge
for Oberyn's death, they've been foiled, until
the Season 5 finale.
Ellaria believes Doran is spineless, but Doran
made Ellaria swear allegiance to him, kissing
his ring, and told her that he believes in
"second chances.
I don't believe in third chances."
So, by poisoning Myrcella, Ellaria has gone
completely against Doran and his strict instructions
not to harm Cersei's daughter.
And if Doran finds she'd resposible for Myrcella's
death, she'll doubtless be punished.
This whole situation will leave Doran's son
Trystane in trouble as he's headed to King's
Landing on the ship with Jaime, Bronn and
Myrcella.
Now the Lannisters have a reason for war against
Dorne and a bargaining chip, or rather, a
means of direct revenge in Trystane, who,
if he ends up in King's Landing, will be in
a much worse position than Myrcella was in
Dorne.
After all, Cersei isn't known for being quite
so, err, diplomatic as Prince Doran.
And remember what happened to the last Dornishman
who had a seat on the Small Council?!
Now, the question is, will Jaime return to
King's Landing or will he turn the ship round
and head straight back to Dorne to confront
them?
After all, Bronn would likely suspect the
Sand Snakes, given his own experience being
poisoned!
I think he'll continue to King's Landing but
I don't think Cersei's going to be too pleased
when he eventually returns with the news about
Myrcella.
Either way, it's been confirmed that the show
will be filming in Spain again for next season,
so it's a safe bet we'll see more of Dorne.
Cersei's Walk of Atonement, as the High Sparrow
called it, was more like a Walk of Shame.
That whole sequence was really full-on and
actually made me feel sorry for Cersei.
But I'm guessing that won't last next season
as I fully expect her to have learned nothing
from her experiences at the hands of the Faith
Militant.
It's unlikely she'll be a reformed character.
She'll probably just have more names on her
hit-list of people to get revenge on in Season
6.
If she wants to stay out of trouble, she better
show a bit more long-term thinking and cunning
as to how she goes about getting revenge.
I mean, this season, she certainly did nothing
to disprove her father Tywin Lannister's words
that "you're not as smart as you think you
are."
But she does have her newest King's Guard,
Ser Robert Strong, on her side, who, according
to Qyburn, has taken a vow of silence until
all Cersei's "enemies are dead and the evil
has been driven from the realm"!
Sounds ominous!
In Season 6, Littlefinger, Olenna and Margaery
Tyrell, Septa Unella, Lancel Lannister, the
High Sparrow, and pretty much anyone and everyone
better watch out, as that guy is a mountain
of a man!
But Cersei had better watch out too if she
tries to take out the High Sparrow as that
could easily cause a rebellion.
Speaking of the High Sparrow, he told Cersei
she'll face a trial to determine whether her
children are bastards, which she denies.
So, who will be lining up to bring evidence?
Given their hardly warm welcome when Cersei
arrived home, Kevan Lannister and Pycelle
seem likely candidates, as does Olenna Tyrell.
Jaime's heading back to King's Landing, so
he could well be called upon to testify too.
But given Cersei's got this huge new King's
Guard at her disposal, it's much more likely
to end up as a Trial By Combat, like we've
seen previously for Tyrion, once with Bronn
representing him and once with Oberyn stepping
up.
Wouldn't it be awesome if Cleganebowl actually
happened?!!
Or could Lancel Lannister step up and fight
for the Faith?
Or total tinfoil hat theory here: what if
Arya took on the face of Sandor Clegane and
fought against the undead Mountain?!!
Now in the books, there's another line in
Maggy the Frog's prophecy to the young Cersei,
but we haven't heard that the show…
at least not yet.
After Maggy told the young Cersei that her
children would die, she added: "And when your
tears have drowned you, the valonqar shall
wrap his hands about your pale white throat
and choke the life from you."
"Valonqar" means "little brother" in High
Valyrian, and this prophecy has doubtless
added to Cersei's hatred of Tyrion over the
years.
So, could this mean that we'll see Tyrion
strangle Cersei, just like he did his former
lover Shae?
Maggy the Frog's other prophecies have certainly
been coming true.
I wonder if it'll be that simple though.
The mountainous man in armour who scooped
Cersei up into his arms after her walk of
atonement is Ser Robert Strong, who was created
by Qyburn from the dying Gregor Clegane.
But earlier this season, Qyburn also took
that decapitated dwarf head that looked a
lot like Tyrion to use for his work.
So, final tinfoil hat theory for this video:
could Qyburn have done a Frankenstein's Monster
and put the Tyrion look-a-like head on top
of the Mountain to make Ser Robert?!
If so, and if Maggy's prophecy comes true,
maybe it's Ser Robert who chokes Cersei…
I mean, the Mountain certainly found it easy
enough to squeeze the life out of Oberyn Martell.
Something to think about!
But if Cleganebowl did happen, then of course,
Sandor Clegane is the "little brother" of
Gregor, so, in that scenario, Sandor could
be the one strangling Cersei!
Now, Qyburn's brought Gregor back from the
dead, maybe he'd like to try doing the same
for Myrcella?
But, frankly, I think one zombie in the Lannister
line-up is enough for Season 6!
Going back to the valonqar prophecy, though,
who do you reckon it will turn out to be?
Could it be Cersei's slightly younger twin
brother, Jaime?!
Then again there’s Tommen, or Trystane Martell,
who’s the youngest son in the books.
Or perhaps Littlefinger, who Catelyn Stark
viewed as a kind of brother?!
Or what about Loras Tyrell, who’s the youngest
son in the books!
Let me know what you think!
So, those are my thoughts on the Lannisters
and Dorne in Season 6.
Don't forget, for a chance to win some goodies
from our friends at Ten Stickers, subscribe
and leave a comment about what you'd like
to see happen in Season 6.
By the way, if you haven't seen it yet, I've
just interviewed Toby Sebastian who plays
Trystane Martell, and you can click here to
watch that video!
If you like this video, do please share it,
hit the thumbs-up button & subscribe for my
weekly reviews and interviews!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
And remember, if you're not watching Jan G
on GoT, you know nothing!